hello assalamu alaikum how are you
mahmoud zaha is back at his gaza home
after two weeks lying low
as a founding member of hamas he is for
israel
a target first of all can you tell us
the status of the ceasefire we're a few
days into it it seems to be holding
yes i think most of the important point
is the degree of
impact on both sides i think
nobody in both sides is looking
for escalation more than what happened
before
so i i believe that it will continue
11 days of conflict between israel and
hamas left 260 dead
most in gaza yet dr zaha claims hamas
achieved a strategic
and symbolic victory the new element
here
is the degree of the resistance movement
in
particular in gaza to attack the israeli
targets
and very important points in including
most of the overcrowded
area in this the civilian civilian
society
so for how long the israeli will accept
that
i think this is the main issue you are
firing
missiles rockets and missiles from
civilian areas
here in gaza this is at civilians
in israel that that's not acceptable is
it that's a war crime no single rockets
were sent from for from the from a
civilian area we
most of the the rockets from the border
that's not true though is it because we
this is a troop
we've seen video of rockets being fired
from within
the the built up area of gaza city at
israeli communities
this is not against the israeli
committee this is against israeli
occupation
are you not at least in part responsible
for the conditions here because you
hamas
spend your money on weapons you spend
your money on tunnels
you spend your money on fighters you are
not spending your money
on the civilian population here give me
one example in the world
that they have no military ministry
to defend themselves we are here
protecting ourselves against aggression
against the israeli aggression
does the state of israel have the right
to exist
no why why
you are coming from america and you take
my house you came from britain and you
took my
brother house you took this is a
settlement
this is a settlement not you are not a
citizen
we are the owner of this is this is area
arabic area will known
this is well known as islamic area well
known so you are
you are telling me now that you you
don't think the two-state solution is
possible
practically practically that was
proved it is not my assessment this is
the nub of the issue this is really
important
if a future israeli government
accepts exactly i'm not answering about
if
i'm not answering if i'm answering
practically
okay practically we the israeli the
palestinian authority
fat father group that organization
accepted two-state solution
go and ask mahmoud abbas are you
now addressing that two-state solution
is viable or not
he will say no so if this question is
practically practically
uh answered why you know we are asking
me well because
it is because you were a founding member
of hamas and if hamas is able to come to
the round the table with a
with the israelis at some stage in the
future then the bloodshed that we are
seeing
if we came to this can stop we came to
the vicious circle
the people went and they sat down on the
table and they signed an agreement and
so and so and so on and
and failed you are now asking me to
practice a failed process
i just really want to understand whether
you
as a palestinian are willing
to share the land with israeli jews
two states we are not one land we are
not against jews
because jews were leaving this area for
long
centuries i'm speaking about occupation
if president biden was willing to sit
down with you with hamas would you talk
to him
why not why not why not
mr biden yes he is supporting israel
but i think we have we have we have a
mission
as a palestinian people to speak to him
frankly
it will come as a relief for many that
senior hamas officials believe this
ceasefire will hold
for now but like so much in this
conflict the gulf between the two sides
remains vast let me ask you one last
thing
how would you define peace peace mean
justice
no peace without justice
on the prospects for long-term peace as
elusive as ever
mark stone sky news in gaza